هذه اللي الناس دائما تقارن انه العطر هذا
يجلس
حق الاطراءات اللي تصنع هنا انه يجلس اربع
ايام ثابت على قناتهم ترى فعليا لو يطلع
بره
يعني
التركيز الكحول تركيز يعني وحش
انا بالنسبه
ترى والله في ناس بدعوا اربع ايام من
الثبات العطر يجلس
العطر ثابت ايام يومين
ترى هذه ترى تضر يعني هذا ما شاء الله اذا
مر جنبك في خط كده
يلا حيهم ضيفنا اليوم عبد الرحمن العليان
الشريك المؤسس لمتجر نايس 1 متجر نايس ون
اذا ما تعرفونه هذا اكبر متجر ميك اب
وعطور في المنطقه وتعدد مبيعاتهم ما شاء
الله 500 مليون ريال في سنه 2022 نسائي
يتابعونا غالبا يعرفونه ببدا الحلقه سولف
مع عبد الرحمن عن بدايته في التجاره
الالكترونيه وكيف بداها بالصدفه في عام
2013 على انستغرام هو طالب في امريكا
وشلون كبر المشروع الى ما رجعوا السعوديه
وحولوا الى متجر الكتروني يخدم دول الخليج
فنغطى مواضيع كثير في الحلقه حول تجربته
في التجاره الالكترونيه فيها المجال مثل
طريقه اختيارهم ومنتجات ليش قرروا يصنعون
منتجاتهم الخاصه وتجاربهم في التسويق مع
المشاهير وكيف تغيرت التجربه هذه مع مرور
السنين وتجاربهم مع طلبات العملاء
والمشاكل يواجهونها في الطلبات مواضيع
كثيره ثانيه هذه من الحلقات اللي صعبه
اختصرها صراحه في المقدمه لان سولفتنا
فيها عن اشياء كثيره جدا وبيريحيه كبيره
ومثل ما تشوفون وقتها طويل نسبيا نسينا
انفسنا واحنا نسولف صراحه فاترككم الان مع
الحلقه واتمنى تستمتعون فيها كثر ما
استمتعت فيها حي الله عبد الرحمن هلا
والله كيف حالك طيب خلينا نخش على
البزنس الماضيه ومتى احنا شف قديم قديمين
انتم بدا بزنس اون لاين 2013
وقت الانستقرام ما كان في سناب شات كان من
البدايه لا ما كان ابدا
هو منتج واحد صدفه
شف احيانا انا دائما اؤمن بشيء اسمه
يعني حظ مو بكل دائما توفيق او توثيق انا
انا ترى مو بذكاء شخص ولا بكل دهانه بكل
شيء لان احيانا حظ وتجربه انك تسوي تبادل
المنتج راح تطلبوه بحثت عنه بامريكا موجود
منتج شعر معروف يمكن كثير من المشاهير
بدات علاقتي
طبعا وقتها ما في شركات تتنافسكم احسن
اعلان تاخذه بالفين ريال ويبيع لك شهر
يعني العائد حقه فوق 150 اكس بس دقيقه انت
كنت في امريكا
العباس استشوار مدري ايش اللي كل شوي يطلع
منتج عسل نفسك فجاه قررت
لقيت بسعر اقل
انا بحبتين يشرونه من تاجر هنا رحت بحثت
لقيته باقل 500
ريالة طبعا
الله ربح كويس اخذت حبتين خويي راجع
سعوديه عطيتني اياه وقلت له اوصلها بس
بس بعت عليهم اول شيء
على طول والله
ناس بعت عليهم بعد رجعت طلبت على طول فكرت
حولت البنت انستغرام صفحه انستغرام
يلا بسم الله
ببدا اسوق فعلا بديت اروح المشاهير قلت
ادخل عليهم
بالبدايه يعني بالذات البزنس
اللي ماسكه التواصل المشاهير
على طول بسم الله
سناب شات يمكن اربع اسامي
تحط قصص مشهوره بالقصص الاسامي مشهوره زي
كذا هم اربع اسامي اللي يذكره عليهم
بالخاص يمكن للحين موجود عندي السلام
عليكم ابغى العب معكم
تاخذه 3000 ريال ببلاش كم العائد كل واحد
من الاعلانات
سويت مخزون اشتري المنتج واحطه بالسعوديه
اخوي عمر عنده انه يوصل هو شريكي طبعا
احنا شركاء هو يوصل المنتج يتكلم مع شركه
الشحن يجي الرصيد الحساب ويطلع
السعوديه صراحه لا كراتين ابي اشحن تكلفه
الشحن على الكرتون كانت يطلع 1200 ريال
بتطلع حقه
ولا تسجيل ولا شيء شخصيه وحتى ترى بدون
يعني وقته ما عندك
يلا توك فاتح سجل مؤسس ولا شيء بالبيت كل
شيء
وتغليف وجهز وتطلع العمل حقيقي طلعت ذاك
الوقت 2013 يمكن مبيعات تجاوزت اربعه
مليون و3 مليون واحد من البيت ترى مبلغ
بسيط
يعني يمكن اللي فرق ترايد كنت ادفع
بالتسويق الناس ما كانت
يعني من كان يقتنع
انا وحده من المشاهير
اعلان واحد ترى وقته مع الناس ما تقتنع
بالتصوير وطلب ما كان عالي اصلا في
الاسعار كانت ولا الشركات كانت شفت متى
دخلت ترى في بعض الشركات بعد عيالهم هم
اللي خربوا السوق اللي فاهمين بالماركتين
زي كذا وهم من اول الناس اللي بدو
بالتسويق بالذات في ناس بالاواني في ناس
زي كذا يعني يصير واحد من العائله هو اللي
فهم ورفع الاسعار علينا يعني قبل ترى ما
في شركات والتاثير يبيع يعني شيء شيء ما
تتخيل وش هي 25 اكس 30 اكس 40 حلو فكملت
انت كنت تدرس في امريكا
امازون
تجاره الكترونيه تابع الناس وشلون اسوي
متجر الكتروني ما افهم ولا بقطاع ترى ترى
ما عندي ولا قطاع فم في يعني يعني ما كان
عندهم ولا قطاع يشتغلون فيه لا ملابس لاي
شيء ابوي معلم والوالده ربت مزه ما في اي
قطع
عائله الظاهر يعني في ذيل انا مؤمن ترى
عموما يعني انا من يوم قعدت وانا صغير
اجلس ناس تتكلم بعشره مليون
ما يعني شيء فعليا بس طبيعي عمك خالك ولد
عمك مدري ايش لكن انا كعائله شخصيا يمكن
حياتي تتغير بسرعه بديت افكر وشلون مدري
ايش
يوميا انا اذكر كنت اكلم عمر
باليوم اربع ساعات خمس ساعات الجوال ترى
نفس السالفه نعيده نبينا افتح متجر
الكتروني نستاجر مقر نحط متجر الكتروني
نبدا نبيع نجيب ملابس
لا عندك منصات ولا مدفوعات ولا توصيل
اللي يخدمني شوي يمكن او يخدمني شوي اني
كنت صراحه كنت اقرا
انا قاعد اطلب منتجي من متجر الكتروني
يعني للحين بعد وصلت تعرفت على السبلاير
وكبار ترى وصلت مرحله ان الوكيل راعي
البراند جاي يقول منه هذا صوت مبيعات
مشتريات ما تروح المورد تروح
تاجر التجزئه
ربطني كذا لين اصلا عندي قناه انه منتج
هابي بيطيح بس متى تحولت بمرحله انستغرام
الى
2016 تقريبا بدات فعليا اني بسوي متجر
الكتروني اول واحد وصلت للزميل اللي اسمه
عبد الله الله يمسي بالخير
بعطيك 5% بس ادخل
الامور تمسك التقنيه
لا كان له اسم مو زين يعني
اول ما عرفت الاسم الناس ترى رسم معك
بعدين وفعلا
رحت الله يعينك بيك
فعليا قال لي بسوي لك المتجر ما ما تمينا
او بنعلي المنصه بس ما كان مركز اعطاني
اليوم منصات جاهزه كانت تسمونه اوبن سورس
اللي منصات جاهزه زي ما قلته زي ذولي ايه
هنا بعدين توجهت للشركه بالبحرين
وسافروا
[موسيقى]
هذولا بنشتغل معهم يعرفون يبيعون
لا لسا هناك أنا للحين اشحن ترى شغلتي
اشحن انا
حقهم
مورد الامريكي
قاعد معهم
قاعد معهم اتفقنا انه يبنوا لنا منصه وحنا
يبنون المنصه جينا استجرنا ما قرب الرياض
ترى ما عندنا ولا شي كذا استجرنا مقر
بدينا بالانستقرام نبيع منتجات تجميل
وشلون نجيب منتجات تجميل اروح للسفاره
بامريكا ادخل المحل ايش تبي 200 دولار
يفتح لي المشتريات اللي بعدها خصم 25%
وعشرين بالمئه اشري ب2000 دولار
وهنا السوق كان غالي هنا كانت توه الهبات
بادي تجي الماركات
شف فيه يمكن البنات يعرفون الغالب انه عام
2015 و16
صار في ترند تاجرات انستجرام ذولي اللي هم
يطلبون يسمون
يسمونه
يجون يطلبون بس مره ضعيفه وليش لانه اول
ما كان في احد عنده بطاقه وهذه تحديات
اللي بقول لك اياها بعد ما نبدا انا بعد
ما بدانا نسوان
انا نفسه اشوف شو يجيبون والله اليوم ترند
مسكره ما اعرف الاشياء اليوم تغير السوق
فاليوم اجلس مع البنات اقول لهم وش صار
على هذه خلاص ما عاد احد يستغفر يعني مثلا
اعرف انه والله الكحل من مدري من البراند
هذا كويس والله الاساس هذا كويس
مشاهير تاخذ افكار هم كلهم عندهم متاجر
مثلا حتى بعضهم يقولون يعني كلهم حنا 70
متر ترى بالانستقرام او 80 التجربه البنات
تقدر
كل نفس المجال بس ترى البنت اقل جراه يمكن
ما حد يقتنع بها وما عنده القرار او ما
عندهاش انا خدمني الكاش حق الكاش حقي
الثاني
طبعا ترى البزنس الاول اللي باربعه مليون
فعليا صافي ارباحي فوق اثنين مليون شو هذا
هذا امتداد
لا هذا الحاله بديت هذا منتجات تجميل
الحال يعني انت بديت منتجات تجميل لسه
شغال
هذا
اخذها احطها هنا ارباح
واحد المنتج عندي ارقام اتذكر اني عرضت
الواحد كان عرضت المستثمر قال لي ارقامك
يعني اشوف حسابه انا وريته انا ما عندي
طبعا محاسب ولا قائم ماليه قلت له كشف
حساب هذا الايرادات
انا جاي من المنتج زي كذا
لو تبيع مئه حبه بشر هذا مدري كميه يعني
معروف عند البنات 2018
على طول المشاركه البحرينيه استجرنا مع قر
200 متر بعلي شارع الضباب قدام مطعم ماما
نوره بالضبط في برلي حق الكفرات
طبعا الحين طلعوا والله كل يوميا اللي
قدام مين داوم للساعه 8:00
في واحد طبعا قبل لا نبدا عمر اخوي راح
استاجر البقر واللي اسس واللي جهز انا ما
كنت موجود في السعوديه صور لي استاجرت كذا
احنا ما نعرف يعني ما من الرياض حسبي علي
يعني
والله
المهم اخذنا المقر
الى الحين عجزنا نطلع منصه
انا بالصدفه مره واحد منزل صوره واحد كاتب
مبرمج
اردني ورقم جواله وادق على المبرمجه
الاردني هذا السلام عليكم كيف حالك
ودي انا عندي متجر الكتروني يبدو انه كان
متعود باي مباراه عليه طلب وكل الناس
يسوون
تطبيق زي ابل زي اوبر ولا زي هنقرستيشن
ولا زي كل الناس بتسوي تطبيقات هذه كل يوم
يجي اتصال
اول ما كلمته قلت له شي موضوع نقل الكفاله
قال لي
قال لي عادي انقل كفاله شوي الولد موظف
جامعه القصيم تقنيه
طلع
منه
يعني
طبعا قريب لي انا حاط رقمي يستهبل او شيء
على الشكل طيب وش رايك
طلع سعودي
انه ما في احد يشتغل الشغله هذه ويداوم
ويقوم الصبح ولا يلبس شماغ ويلبس بدله
ومدري ايش
اردني اليوم
المهم تكلمت بالجوال جلسناه قلت له شوف
اسمه كم راتب كام راتبي الظاهر 8000
بعطيك نفس الراتب حقك وبعطيك شيء ثاني
انت عارف اللي بيمخالتهم
شركه تقنيه تخدم مشروعك عشان شركه تقنيه
وليش كنت تسوي شركه تقنيه عشان اخدم
مشروعي
حلو ما بعد سويت
اول ما اجتمعنا سوينا فعلا شركه شركه
مايار للتسويق
اسمه ايار للتسويق التسويق التسويق الرقمي
طبعا اللي هو تويتر ومدري ايش اداره
حسابات وكذا
وفيها البرمجه والتقنيه نبني صفحات اي شيء
بنكوش على كل شيء فعليا مع بعض سوى المتجر
هو
المتجر
وبدينا بالشركه قعدنا شهرين والله هنا
بديت ارقام
واحد واحد 2017 اول يوم بدينا
احنا قبل لا نبدا جبنا ملابس شنط جبنا كل
شيء قبل نبدا بيوم جلست انا وواحد شارع
التحليه بالضبط
ما تفكر تتخصص يعني انك ما تبدا بشيء واحد
بعدين تتوسع ضربت براسي شوي
ايوه تخصص بشيء واحد شلون فعلا انا مش
اقوى شيء فيه فاهم فيه انا شاري ترى ملابس
وقاضي شاري بضاعه ب 200,000 مشاري احذيه
رحمه بجد سوق باب البلد
ومدري ايش كله بالمستودع هذه الحين بنبدا
واحد واحد
اليوم كلمت عمر قلت ايش رايك نوقف متخصص
نبدا بس بالمكياج خليك بنجيهم بعدين
انه عشان ما نتشتت وزي كذا
لا انا اكثر شيء افهم فيه المكياج فيه سنه
قبل تصريح غريب
اشتغلت فيها
الملابس
الحين تدري يقف على اي نوع من النوع
المكياج يمسح يدري هذا
خامته زينه ولا لا بالمعارض انه يطول يشوف
الماء يعني
يمكن ما افهم بالتفاصيل زي ما يفهم
المهم
تخصصنا تخصصت بسم الله تخصصنا او
تحولتة مكياج بس مكياج لانك تبيع كثير
اسولف قابلتر
ما ادري عاد
من الطف الناس الصراحه اللي قابلته
هذه هي الشيء الوحيد اللي غيرها قال
المنخفضلي
استثمار انا فعلا الحين احتاج كاش يعني
البزنس حقي لاني شفت المبلغ اللي بعت
باربعه مليون صفيت 2 مليون طبعا انا فعليا
صرفته انا واخوي صرفناه
ما شاء الله
ففعليا صرفنا المبلغ كامل طبعا الحمد لله
يعني كل واحد صرفه بشيء زين ما يعني ما
صرفناه صرفناه يعني غالبا كان يعني غالب
كان بالبيت او بيت اهلي او شيء بيتنا
والوضع نهائي كان كلهم صرف بالعائله
تقريبا طبعا الحين ما نص بالرياض جيب
القصيم جيب والله لا تجيب ففعليا انا اقول
بيت جديد
وغيرنا السيارات وفجاه كل شيء يتغير عندك
[موسيقى]
فانت اليوم اتذكر فعليا بدا ب 500 الف
تقريبا
كمكتب 250 مع تاثير مع تجهيز اول ما شجر
المكتب
جبنا واحد قال بسوي لكم المكتب الظاهر 400
400 الف كان عمر اخوي خلاص وشو جاب المخطط
وكل شيء قال تدري لا نفس المخطط نفذناه
وب70 الف جبنا عمال من القصيم وحاسب بند
مثلا
الجبسون بورد المتر ب 40 متر بعشرين حاسب
البلاطه المتر بخمسين يعني التكييف حاط لك
اشياء فهو هذه يمكن جانب من شغلتنا شويه
فرجع ملفات محنه نفس المشروع سبعين الف
نفس المكتب كلف 70 الف ريال
فاجار مكتب ماكينه بضاعه تقريبا 250 كانت
بضاعه المكياج الفعليه
هنا اللي فرق وشو انه اخوي بدا ينزل للسوق
وهذه نقطه تحول انك تنزل للسوق انك تنزل
تتعرف على التجار الجمله بمجال
كنا رحت الجرى الجمله طبعا ما في ولا
سعودي ترى بالقطاع نادر في في بس عدد قليل
اسامي الى يومك انا اشتغل معاه فنزل
بالسوق الغالب
حق الميك اب
احيانا تطلعوا ارخص من انا ما اجيب لان
كميات اكثر ويعرفون طرق يجيبون كل شيء
فانا كنت اعتقد اني جايب الزبدهم جايبينها
احسن
فنزل يتعرف على التجار الجمله كل شيء
يقولون وين تبيع يقول
الى
تجاره الكترونيه ولا شيء
وبدات تنبني الثقه هنا وشفارق معنا
احنا تعدينا طبعا سالفه
اعطاني اياه
برجع له شوي بعدين نرجع للكميه العمر لما
جلست معه قال لي عبد الرحمن شوف بزنس ترى
بعدين بحتاج كاش لا تبيع اكثر من المبلغ
اللي انت تحتاجه يعني لا تبيع حصه بيوم
باربعين بالمئه
كم تحتاج قلت انا احتاج مثلا كذا المبلغ
هذا عمر الصناديق ذي ترى ما يعطونك الفلوس
ترى ياخذون وقتهم يشوفونك يقولون لك اشياء
يجلسون معك بعد شهر بعد شهرين هم ما يمهم
ياخذونك الحين عادي ينتظرون 3 شهور لين
تمضج اكثر شوي يقدرون على سنه ولا لا
انا عدت منها
قاعده اشوف نمو وش اللي كان قاتلني
الصراحه انا التجاري اعطوني فلوس ترى يمكن
انا يخدم بزنس من المشاريع الثانيه انا
كتجزع انه انا اكبر بفلوس التجار مو
بفلوسي تاجر يعطيك فلوس انت تاخذها ترجع
تسددها بعد 60 يوم تبيع البضاعه تسدد بعد
كاش
انك تدفع بالعجل وتبيع بضاعه وترجع تشتغل
فلوس الناس تحاسب فلوس الناس تقدر تسوق
بفلوس التاجر تقدر تكبر بفلوس التاجر بس
اذا عرفت تدير الكاش لما اشوف هذا ما كنت
اعرف يمكن اكثر واحد فنان بالمجال اخوي
عمر ما شاء الله
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
اكثر انت الحين
يعطونك
اول تاجر جلست معه طبعا انا جلست مع واحد
ما كنا نعرف العاجل ولا وشو
تعرف ترى ولا شيء وهذه اشياء
فجلس اخوي مع واحد قال له
المستثمرين يعني قال له غلط
حلو انك تلقط كلمات ذي ترى
يعني
30 يوم فرحنا نفس الشيء التاج هم عندهم بس
هو مبسوطه تاجر انت تشتري كاش شبيك كاش
فبدانا مع التاجر الاف خمسه عشره الاف
يعطيك
ترى تلقائيا ترتفع وانت ما زال كل ما
اعطيك مساحه اكبر سواء في الايام واحده من
المراحل قد واحد من التجار وهذه بداياتنا
ترى مو فتره متاخره كان عندي موسم جينا
كلمناه قلنا له حنا عندنا موسم
وزي كذا نزل بضاعه قيمته فوق مليونين ترى
يعني بضاعه مو بسيطه
ومشى بدون ولا ورقه ولا اي شيء ولا اي شيء
هذا البضاعه حسبكم بعد الموسم كان
وطرد تمبلي ثقتك بالسداد وهم اذا قال لك
مثلا بتسدد بعد خلينا نقول
ممكن أنت تصرف البضاعه بعشر ايام ويصير
عندك كاش معدل دوران المخزون حقك هذا ترجع
تشتري وتسدد ترجع
وتستخدمتنا بس كان عندنا احتياجات ثاني مو
بس بضاعه او كانت عندنا مشكله اكبر كم
تتوقع كان حجم الكاشن دليفري اللي هو
الدفع عند الاستلام
2017 2018 هو الاغلبيه 95% مستحيل
عشان تاخذ الكاش حقك
عمليه تحصيل من الشركات الشاحن الحين
شركات الشاحن يعطونك بخمسه ايام اسبوع
35 يوم 30 يوم بعدين عشره ايام
يوم عشره ايام على ما تسوي المخالصه بينك
وبينهم المطابقه
ابي كاش انا اشوف سوق اشوف طلبات اشوف نمو
شوف سوق السواقين
ده عليه رسوم ممكن بس شوف السوق يساعد
اعلان واحد
دور بدون واسطه شركه معينه عشان سعر شحن
عشان تاخد سعر وانا لا لاني بنيت علاقه
قبل فكان وضعي كويس شوي
بالقصيم وبعدين فتح لي اكاونت مانجر هنا
وبعدين ضبطت العلاقه المهم انا قاعد اشوف
طبعا المعلوميه الشحن كان لما يجي طلب ما
عندنا ربط بالسيستم ناخذ الرسم الرقم
وعندنا السيستم بنفس الشركه دي نكتب في
اسم العميل والحي وكذا ونشحنه يعني ما في
ما في ربط على طول يدوي الشحنه كل يوم
نكتبه بالاكسل وبعدين نرفع السيستم حق
الشركه
كانت مشكله الكاش ابي اي كاش فانا امتلت
ادور على طول فلان فلان ابي اي كاش اول
اثنين مستثمرين
[موسيقى]
يعني
مثلا بعطيك رقم بيع تقريبا بسبعه مليون
اول سنه 2017
فكل شهر تركت انمو يعني الشغله الاول مثلا
انا بعد ثلاث مئه الف ترى الرابع 500 الف
يعني نمو شهري فجيت الرجل العماني قلت له
ادخل معي كشف انا بس
طبعا اعطاني واحد تقييم او جاني تقييم
اكتشف انا بمبلغ بسيط ابي مليون و6 بس
مقابل كم
مقابل عشره بالمئه
فمن قال لي قال لي
عمره مجزوع قال لي اذكر اعطاني مبدئيا كم
تقييمي علمني وشل قيمه الحقيقيه يعني قال
لي ترى كانت تنمو كذا ترى تقييم كذا
واعطاني مبدئيا بس ما خلص معي ما قفل
من الدين لانه كان متردد بيني وبين واحد
من المنافسين فهو
المهم
انا عرفت قيمتي تقريبا عرفت ان القيمه
السوقيه حقتي هذه توقعت عادل 18 او شيء زي
كذا انه عشره بالميه مقابل مليون وثمان
الشخص هذا التاجر قلت له انا بعطيك خمسه
مليون باخد اربعين بالمئه
مغريه ترى
قلت له انا ما ابي انه على قيمتك اليوم
عطني يعني زي عطني مبلغ أقل بس خذ حصه
اصغر لاني انا عرفت وشو الجوله الاولى
جوله ثانيه جوله ثالثه ولازم تحافظ على
حصتك الاكبر عشان تقدر تكبر بعدين في
نظامك اللي يجي يقول لك تعال خمسين بالمئه
قريب وصديق
صراحه شافوا حياتي يعني فجاه تغيرت صار
معي سياره زين يشوفون الناس حياتك قلت له
انا عندي مشروع كذا كذا
المبلغ اللي هو مليون وخمس تقريبا يا
مليون وخمس
دائما ترى اول ناس تستثمر فيك الناس اللي
حواليك او الناس اللي انت تبني علاقات
معهم تروح تعرف انا عند المبلغ ترى هذولا
يوم ما يرفعونك فوق يا أمان نايم من هونك
الصراحه يعني يصيرون بحلق كتاب لك انا
يمكن توفقت الحمد لله بكل مراحل
الاستثمانيه كل المراحل استثمار توفقت
بشركاء يعني رهيبين
خلصنا خلصنا الصفقه معهم على طول من بكره
استاجرنا مستودع ساحته تقريبا الف متر
بدينا نحط الحديد ما نعرف شلف ولا
مستودعات ولا اي شيء ترى ما كل شيء جديد
علينا نتعلم قاعدين كل يوم نتعلم اسافر
لجده افلام عنده متجر الكتروني شوف شو
مزين هالقط من هذا معلومه اخذ من هذا
معلومه افتح اليوتيوب واتفرج كلنا نتعلم
حنا ثلاث اشخاص
انا واخوي عمر وبندره ماسك الاي تيوب
طبعا اليوم ما شاء الله يعني
اللي هو حجم التيم اليوم تحته 50 موظف
تقريبا ما بين
الامانه يعني في اشياء كانت ايجابيه عندنا
كيف نستثمر بالاشخاص صراحه
انا وعمر ندفع يعني انا اذكر وظفنا ناس
اعلى منه رواتب يعني
معلومه واحده فتحنا سوق جديد افتح لي سوق
كامل هو اللي يفتح سوق العطور لما جبته خط
من مكان كبات وعشره طلعته من المكان هذا
هو فتح لي السوق
ترى المورد ده طلع يعني طلعت فيه من فوق
ومورد فوق مورد فوق مورد فوق الشركات يعني
سلسله تكبر خلاص انت كلما تكبر اصلا
توضحلك
هو كان مجرى الكتروني مشهور موجود
بالسعوديه
وانا على طول مع مبدا استقطاب هذول دور
يعني احترم المنافسين فانا رحت شفته طلع
كان عامل بالمستودع ولا شيء يعني
[موسيقى]
زي كذا بس يدري انه هذا المورد
جاء عندي صار مدير بزنس
فتح لي اصوات جديده
ولكن حتى ما ابعد عن الموضوع نرجع موضوع
الاساسي للاستثمار
اول ما اخذنا الاستثمار على طول
كم
مستودع مدري ايش بسرعه بدينا حجم النمو ما
بين السنه الاولى الى السنه الثانيه 15
يمكن
ما راح اعطيه بالضبط ولكن
سبعه مليون مثلا السنه الثانيه بعنا
تقريبا بحوالي
اكثر من خمسين ما شاء الله
تقريبا يعني ممكن سبعين
هذا دخلنا العطور احنا بعد ثمانيه شهور
على طول بعد سبع شهور
تراني اني اوصل الشيء هذا على الاستثمار
انا دائما اقول لا تستحي انك تاخذ استثمار
مهم بعد ما كملنا سنه تقريبا جاني مستثمر
ثاني وعرض
تقريبا
[موسيقى]
يعني ثلاث اضعاف بالقيمه اللي احنا
موجودين فيها جيت الشركه اللي معي قالوا
حنا خلاص تكفينا ما قصرت جزاك الله خير
اللي داخل ب 8006 على طول خلوهم
ونفس الشيء حنا سوينا زياده راس مال لا
طريقه طبعا معينه
وخلصناة خذنا المبلغ ما كان يعني شوي كان
بالنسبه لي كبير خلاني اتطور خمس اضعاف
اقل من 20 مليون
ريال طبعا او اقل من 15 مليون تقريبا بس
هذا المبلغ
فعليا صار عندي شركاء جداد وبالمبلغ هذا
هنا بدات حياه جديده عندك شركاء معك كاش
تقدر تتفاوض تقدر تشتري بدا يدخل كريدت
بدا يدخل المدفعات على طول تغير البزنس
صرنا جاهزين
صرنا اكثر ناس جاهزين وصلنا عندنا تقنيه
عندنا فريق ندفع
تجيني باليوم
يعني حتى شركات كبار صارت يعني انا اول في
شركات اروح عند الباب تكفى يا ابن الحلال
خلينا نشتغل معكم اليوم يجي عندي
وانا اطلب طلباتي مو بولي اطلب يعني انا
اليوم انا اختار الربح حقي انا الاكبر
بالسوق يعني انا اليوم اكبر من مجموعه عدد
كبير مثلا من الصيدليات طبعا كلها
باسمها
غريب
قلنا ناعس موجود قلنا ايش رايك نايس 1 شوف
صدفه بالتفاصيل بس كان بيني وبين اخوي
يعني طلع شلون بالضبط ما ادري
ترى لسه احيانا كثر ما يتكرر يصير سهل
للناس ولا مو بشرط انه الاحسن
بس يعني انا قلت لك اشياء كثيره انا اقول
لك البزنس حقنا يعني انا لا افهم استثمار
ولا اعرف استثمار ولا اعرف شيء ولا اعرف
التفاصيل بس كلها قعدت تمر علي وتجيك
احيانا انت بس مجرد بديت طقت الباب تبدا
الناس تتعلم حلو انت الحين اخذنا يمكن
الحين قصه التاسيس وكيف قدرت تكبرون
المتجر توصلون للمنتجات اللي انتم ماشين
عليهم البزنس احبه احبه من اكثر من زاويه
اولها في موضوع المنتجات ما ذكرت انه عطر
ميكب التخصص الى اليوم حتى دخلنا قطاعات
وطلعنا جربنا الالكترونيات دخلنا فتره
دخلنا النظارات وطلع لها علاقه بالنساء
الكترونيات اللي هي دخلنا شواحن فتره صرنا
نبيع فجاه
عندي عملاء داخلين يطلبون كل يوم احط له
سلك واحط
والله بس اكتشف ما في
محروق الهواء مش الربح محروق
كل الناس تتهاوش عليها بعدين
تزوجت
انا اول سؤال المنتجات
تذكر مدري اذا اليوم
المنصات اللي هي يسمونه طبعا في نوعين من
التركتونيه
نهائيا يعني
شوف انا بقول لك الناس اللي ما تقتنع
بالعطور فعليا هذه هذه مشكله
طبعا اليوم أنا
والمحلات الكبارين وزي كذا اخذ من مورد
واحد هي اصلا ثلاثه شركات معروفه او اربع
شركات معروفه بالسوق موردين كبار احنا
بالغالب نتعامل معهم يعني ولا يعني ما
اقدر اذكر اساميهم حاليا يعني
ليش ذكرتي
لك بالسوق معروفين اللي يملكون تجاره
العطور كان
انا وش اللي افرق معي
اليوم انت كمحل بتبيع ترى ما تقدر تبيع
باليوم اكثر من 15 عطر
ليش بمحل زي محل
فاذا
عاليه يعني لازم نعرف حنا انه العطر قيمته
100 ريال ترى مو بلا اذا 110 ريال يعني
انت ربحان لا خسرانه ما تكفيها عندك تشغيل
وعندك اللي ينباع قليل لان العدد قليل ليه
احنا انا بايع بايع مكياج فالعطر ما يشكل
شيء فعليا اليوم اقل هوامش ارباح العطور
كم تقريبا نسبه ما اقدر اعطي الصراحه
تفاصيل بخصوص الهوامش كلها ولكن
بالضبط ولكن هواء مش زينه ابدا ابدا يعني
العطور
اليوم ترى حنا نملك وكالات يمكن
للناس اللي يشتغل
بكثير اي شيء لما يصير توه جاي كانت
الروج بخمسين
كانت عاليه يعني زي
كانت مثلا او اشياء ماركات العالميه ذي
كان ما موجود هنا يعني محلات غاليه هنا
مره كان والوكله اللي هنا غاليين بشكل
يعني انت تشتري من برا بسعر تجزئه ارخص من
هنا وتبيعه وتربحان ارخص من اللي هنا
الى الى وقت قريب اليوم
الاسعار تتغير يعني شفت الوكاله الكبار
اللي بالسعوديه اول والله ياخذون الهوامش
صراحه خيال اليوم السوق ضغط عليهم السوق
مفتوح ترى ما عاد زي اول
وش اللي يحدد الحين اول كنت اختار منتجات
على المشاهير اليوم
والله حنا نشوف يعني هذا اللي يفرقه حنا
عن المعارض الكبار واللي خلالها اميز ليش
الناس يقولون ليش البنات يروحون ما يروحون
لذاك المتجر مثلا عالمي المعروف هذا ما
يقدر يمشي مع الهبد انا امشي مع الهبه
البراند هذا ترند اجيبه الكريم هذا ترند
هذا
بسرعه تغير باليوم يعني لازم انزل بالسوق
يوميا وافهم كل يوم يعني بس قاعد المكتب
لا لا لازم أدري
بس تتابع الهبات عن طريق المشاهير مشاهير
الحياه الاجتماعيه كل شيء الناس الي حولي
موظفين من المكتب البنات كلهم الحين
العملاء هم اللي يقترحون مو بنت اليوم
عميلك هو اللي يقول
ارجع لك العطور انا اليوم اقول لك انا
شهريا ابيع ما لا يقل عن 100,000 حبه في
بعضها في الشهر ولا في الشهر
عادي باليوم توصل مثلا اقول لك الى 4000
3000 عطر في مراحل عشره الاف ترى هذه ما
يقدر اي محل مستحيل يقدر يبيع العددها
فاحنا هو مجتمع العطور بالغالب زي ما تكون
نبيع
انا
يوم خسرنا ما قد معنا شيء بخساره يعني ما
نبيع بخساره نهائيا ولا عندي نظام الشخص
اللي خسر علشان احرقه انا ما عمري سويته
نهائيا دائما امشي بسعر واحط ربحي المعقول
اللي يرضي يرضي يرضيني يرضيه العميل وحتى
اني اقدر استمر واقدر اقدم خدمه
العطور بهذا العطور مثلا عطر السياره مثلا
700 الف ريال بالمحل علشان يبيعها ويقدر
يربح وكذا لازم يبيع ب 1400 ريال مثلا انا
ابيعها ب 170 ريال عشان اقدر تكاليف المحل
عشان اقدر انا ابيع ب 1700 ريال
بعض العطور يعني يكفي ربح بسيط ليش
عطور العطور عليها طلب فتبيعها بهامش قليل
بالضبط بحيث تاخذ فلوس وتبيع تصرفها ب 15
يوم وتبدا تشتغل بفلوس
طبعا الموضوع طويل هو هذا البزنس كمثال
فقط
يعني باي قطاع بنفس الشيء في بزنس يجيب
فلوس عشان تقدر أي لا وانا بعدين اكتشفت
اني صرت اكبر بسرعه بالمجال يعني
انك تبيعي للعدد من العطور يعني انت يعني
الشركات كبار صارت تنزل دمك تنزل
في المنتجات العطور
وفعلا هذه تصير ترى دائما الناس عنده
مشكله بالعطور اللي هي
هو شارب بعض الناس
خاصه مع السعر يمكن
فيبدا يبدا يتخيل الريحه مثبتات مدري ايش
وزي كذا لا العطور معروف انا صارت لي قصه
الحين بقول لك اياه يعني
ومع عميله وما ابطه دخلت علي وحده بتويتر
شوف انا ما اقدر اترك العميل من المرحله
ترى مزعجه انك ترد على الناس او انك
شويه تخليك تحسن شغلي غلط وانت شغلك صح
يمكن ولا شيء لو تجي لرقام تتخذ قرار
احيانا ترى احيانا قراري يضيعك وهذه انا
عرفتها بعدين لا تتخذ قرارك بناء على واحد
يجيك او واحد يكلمك مثلا واحد يقول لك
الرز حقكم مالحه يمكن هو لسانه طيب ماله
فيخليك تاخد روح تغير الطباخ وتتهاوش مع
المطعم بناء على كلام لا دائما ارجع
للبيانات
هذاك اليوم حسبي الله عليك ونعم الوكيل
طبعا انا عندي قاعده ترى ما اذا شريت شيء
ما عجبك قلت تعال خذ فلوسك ترى محتاج ولا
يضيق صدري ولا شيء خذوا فلوسكم وخلي
المنتج عندك بعد ولا اذا المنتج غالي ناخذ
نرجعه ما عندنا مشكله يعني انا يعني
بالنهايه النسبه دي ما تشكل شيء عندي
العملاء اللي مو راضي
المجالات للعميله انه زي كذا مدري ايش قلت
له طيب انت من وين تشترين عطورك 20 من
المحل الفلاني
طيب اكيد عندك نفس العطر وقارنتي قلت له
طيب هو يمكن انا هذي مقصوده قلت له يمكن
حنا مشكله
خليني بشحن لك واحد ثاني من عندنا وارسل
السواق او نفس السواق هنا انا واخوي عمر
مشتركين من الموضوع نرسل السواق نفس المحل
اللي تقول وياخذ قلت له خذ الفاتوره وخلى
عندك
وسواق الشخصي ترى ما هو الشركه وديه وديه
لك هذا بدال المنتجه يومين اعطينا خط قالت
انتم بعد نصابين نفس تقول كذا قلت لا اقول
لك شيء اقسم بالله العظيم هذا فاتورتك هذا
عطرك من هذا المحل تشتج على راسك لا انا
احيانا يعني ودي افهم الناس ليش تقول كذا
انا ودي افهم ليش قالت قلت روحي خذي
المنتج وحط قالت انا اسفه واعتذر مدري ايش
طبعا انت ما تقدر تقتنع كل الناس يعني
حتى ترى بنفس
بالنهايه العميل ترى اللي يتكلم ذا ترى
هذا تاث
[موسيقى]
وهذه تعلمك بعدين
يعني شوف لما حجمك صغير تقدر الو السلام
عليكم تجيب لي 25 حبه 30 حبه خذ رجعها لما
توصل المرحله اليوم ترى حنا عندنا 25 الف
صن 25 الف كيلو لما يصير عندك حجم المخزون
يبغى لك ناس تحلى للمخزون وناس تعرف شلون
تطلب ناس تعرف تسويها انا يعني اشياء طبعا
هذا علم كامل انا ما اقدر فيه لازم اكيد
له فريق كل شيء
مطبات اكلنا كمامات كورونا اكلنا
جزومين عمر اخوي مو بيخاف
البزنس مو بيخاف اذكر اول ما جت كلمت طبعا
احنا نتعامل مع الصين احنا نصنع اليوم
نصنع براندات ونصنع
فراشة ونصرنا عدسات وصلنا اشياء كثيره
فتذكر عرضوا علينا صفقه كمامات كم 12
مليون كمامه
وبتوصل يوم تشوف يوم كانت سعر الكمامه
تقريبا الكرتون كان 50 ريال في السعوديه
حنا اتصلنا بخمسه وثلاثين ريال يعني خلني
بكسر السوق انا ببيعها بخمسه واربعين او
باربعين بسيطر كان في عشرين واحد فكر زيك
لا احنا طلبنا مو فكرنا
هو صار شيء ما ادري
فعليا وقفت بالجمارك هل من يوم جيت تطلع
هناك هل في ناس ما في شيء صار بس فعليا
المفروض نستلم عشره ايام استلمنا خلال شهر
صار الكرتون وصل عشره ريال
والله صراحه
مع كل طلب كمامات صارت دعايته مره رهيبه
ما تخيلنا صارت احسن من اني
حاط
صرنا نحطه
وش التقدير ذا اللي ترسل لي كلمات
شف اليوم عشان كذا يوم تقول لي لا تدخل
مجال صعب اليوم السوق مره انكشف يعني مو
مثل الاول
الواحد عشان يسوي متجر بعشر دقايق تحزر
يضغط يشترك مع منصه جاهزه وتراهم اداهم
مره رهيب واي واحد بيبدا انا اقول له ترى
هذا الخيار كويس
اللي هي المنصات المفتوحه الجاهزه زي سل
وزد
والحقيقه يعني اتمنى لو يوم ابدا كان زد
موجود ولا كان انا اروح مباشره ما عقد
اتجه للمشاكل التقليليه مريته فاليوم اسهل
واحد بس اليوم الصعوبه
دور قطاع مو مفتوح قطاع جديد طبعا قطاعنا
اليوم في كبارين يلاقون بالسوق يعني وصعب
يعني مثلا اليوم واحد بيسوي تطبيق توصيل
طلبات اقول له لا تدخل انت قادر على اوبر
تقعد
كريم طلعت من كريم فود الناس اللي تحارب
كبار بالسوق ناس تتكلم عن شركات يعني
تمتلك بليرات فدائما لا تدخل سوق يعني انا
الوقت اللي دخلت فيه ما كان في احد اصلا
ما كان في ترى لا نون ولا متاجر ولا شيء
كان موجود سوق كم قبل لا يجي امازون يعني
خمسه اعرفهم يعني هذا كلنا عنده منصه خاصه
هذا الكاس 500 لو بالمحل ميت بيعه
بالانستجرام ب 500 ينباع فعليا
شغال اشتري من سوق الجمله بمئه وموجود
بالمحلات بجنبي
وكمل بقطاع الولد ما شاء الله ناجح اليوم
لانه احنا وصلنا انه صارت الربحيه سوق
مستحيله عشان كذا اقول لك صعبه حتى تصنيع
وش تصنع البدايه غير موضوع الربحيه لانك
مثلا في منتجات موجوده ونفس المنتجات انا
اليوم عندي عندي البيانات كلها كل
البيانات التجار انا بزر لا ادري هذا
اللون هذا يمشي هذا لن تخلق منتج جديد ولا
تنسخ منتج موجود احنا اشتغلنا على نوعين
الصراحه اشتغلنا اخذنا وكالات قويه يعني
كانت مع شركات كبيره قبل وطلعت وزي كذا
انا
يعني
يجي يلمع الوكيل يقول عندك تارجت بس انا
مثلا كذا عشان تاخذ ما حد يقدر ياخذه
بالسوق لانه علماء ويبني مدري ايش في عدد
معين لازم عشان يكبر انا ايه مثلا يقول لي
انت اطلب منك كذا اسوي الطلب الاول ولا
اسوي اكثر من التارجت حقه صارت هو يعطيني
تارك يتاقل يعني
عندك طريقه يعني انت لما تصير كبير يتغير
معك والتصنيع
ليش
اجهزه مثلا قطاعات
اسفنج اشياء يعني فعليا يحتاجونها الناس
وتقدر توصل نفس المصنع اللي يصنع فيه
الماركه المشهوره دي وهذا فن التصنيع في
ناس كثير جابته اخذوا ماركه كامله راحت
جابها زي كذا وصارت باسمه حتى من مشاهير
زي كذا
الكحل ناجح مثلا بايطاليا
حق البشره ناجح بكوريا المصنع هذا اللي
المانيا متخصص بالشيء ذا اذا عرفت تركب
الخلطه ذي تقدر تطلع بشيء جوده عاليه
وسعره مناسب بس كمنتج تصنع المواد من اكثر
دوله
كل نوع من المنتج منتج العين يختلف عن
منتج البشره هذا بعده دول عده دول تقدر
تركب التركيبه هذه حنا وش نشوف حنا
بالامانه يعني عندنا البيانات هو فقط
موضوع اوامر وليس انك تبغى تغطي نقص في
منتجات الا تغطي يعني هي وامش وتطور في
كان في ماركات تصنع وناس تصنع هنا تسمى
براندات اقل هذول مو قادرين يعني
ما اقدر اشوف كل البيانات في البيانات انا
عندي البيانات اشوف اللون هذا يمشي اكثر
يعني اشوف كل الداتا في المنتجات حتى
الموجود شلون تغطي النكس في المنتجات مو
بس مو بتاخذ شي موجود وتقول بسوي زيه
احتياج الناس والبحث مش الناس تبحث عنها
الصيف وش يمشي وش الالوان اللي كذا هذه
ترى ما يقدر حتى لو هو يصنع وتاجر ما يقدر
اذا ما عنده بيانات لازم شيء البيانات
اللي تطلع لك كل شيء
والتصنيع والوكالات موضوع التسويق
فلكيه المفروض احنا من يوم بدينا كان موزع
العمل بيني انا وعمر على جزئين عمر ماسك
جانب الماليه سواء اعرف للكاش يعرف يدير
فلوس فلينا عارف الفلوس ولو الكاش عندي
كان ضاع منور اي والله انا علي تكفى انا
محتاج فلوس بس اهدد كنت خلاص
ما عندي 60 يوم 90 يوم اصبر عندي ازمه كاش
عادي تص شويه لازم تعرف
اداره الكاش اداره مو بشيء مو بسيط ابدا
مو بسيط انا هذا شيء ما افهم فيه تجي تقول
لي
بالمستودعات والاتمه والاشياء هذه غالبا
عمر هو اللي يفهم فيها اليوم يعني يمكن من
اول الناس الشركات تطبق الاتمته والاشياء
التسويق من يوم بدينا مسكت الجانب التسويق
والتقنيه كتطوير المنتج نفسه كتطبيق
والاشياء هذه ما بين التوظيف من بين كل
شيء
شف التسويق 2017 مختلف على الحين صعب
اليوم لو ما عندك فريق قوي لو ما تصرف لو
ما تخسر ما تنجح
طبعا 2017 ما عندك شيء اسمه قياس ما شاء
الله تداول ولا كم العاهد ولا روائي
المشاهير ويا ربك خمس مشاهير باخر الشهر
تبيع ب 500000 السلام عليكم دافع عن
الاقتراض المشاهير كلهم وبايع مليون مش
مليون يمكن خلاص هذا العائد كويس
حتى لو ما نجح اصلا اول اذا جاب الف طلب
مشهور فعليا الف طلب خلينا نقوم متوسطه
الطلب خلينا نقول
يعني كمل عادي يسمونه اعاده التسويقيه
اتوقع انا مو بجيد
فمن 7000 فوق العشرين فوق العشرين يعني
اللي هو معدل
اول لو جاب زي كذا يعطيك صدرك ها زين تدق
عليه وتقول له رجع فلوس ولا اعلم من جديد
وتكفى مدري وشخص راح اسوي لك تذكير مجاني
اليوم لو تدفع عشرين الف على واربعين الف
يبيع لك
اثنين يعني اربعين جابت 80 شكرا
اليوم يعني في بعضهم انا ماني
لكن اليوم انا واصل مرحله بس انا طبعا انا
مازلت أعلم مع المشاهير مع انه النتائج
دائما يعني اقولها انا اتحمل اني اغامر
واخسر لما اسوي حمله اخذ 100 اسم ترى عندي
اسم ادفع عليه 20,000 ذاك الوقت يعني في
شيء خوارزميات سناب يسويها ويشيل
المشاهدات او شيء تخيلي دافع عشرين الف
لواحد ما جاب لي ولا طلب شوف ولا طلب
مع انه قبل قد جاب لي 400 طن
احيانا مشاهدات تروح في شيء قاعد يصير
فاليوم اللي بزنس وهذا لو يعلن كذا مره ما
عاد يعلن خاصه مشاهير فيطلع انا لا عادي
يعني اتحمل انه كامل حمل يعني نقيسها من
قياس ثاني انه صرفته الشهر هذا على
المشاهير
نفترض مليون ريال جابولي اثنين مليون ونص
بالنسبه لي اوكي كويس بس ترى في واحد منهم
جاب رقم كبير واحد منهم جاب صغير فانا
اقيسها مجمل بقيسك ميزانيه تصرف على
المشاهير بالضبط
حتى كمل ضغط على المحاوله كمل رابط يا كود
الرابط الغالب يقدر يطلع لك كل شيء مربوط
المنصات هذه عشان تعرف اللي يشترك او
الكون ما يعطيك احيانا بشكل دقيق لانه
احيانا يصير عندك اكواد ثانيه ولا شيء
ف مو بشرط في طرق ثاني كثيره انا اليوم
يعني اقول لك
[موسيقى]
مقابل كل دولار او مقابل كل ريال خمسه
ريال مقابل كلاريال سبعه ريال مقابل
انا استثمرت
بالتسويق الرقمي من البدايه ووظفت يعني
وطورت وتطورت
فاليوم يمكن اقول لك قسمت ميزانيتي الثلاث
اقسام ما بين والله اربعين بالمئه
اليوم اصرفها ديجيتال 30% مثلا مشاهير
وعشرين بالميه مثلا اصرفها
ورعايات واشياء تصرف بالشوارع انا العام
صار فوق 12 مليون
انا مقتنع انه لازم شوف في حجم
في حاجه متفكر انا اليوم لو عندي متجر
جديد
بس انا في مرحله اليوم لا ابي ابي ظهورك
اكثر وش الشيء اللي يوم سويته شوارع في
شوف انا اليوم بالتسويق وصلت شوي قناعه
انه ترى مو بشرط المنصه هذه تجيب لك
التاثير
يمكن لربطت ثلاث اشياء مع بعض لو بحمله
واحده اعلنت مشاهير واعلنت ديجيتال واعلنت
شارع ترى التاثير يرجع كله على الديجيتال
يزود
يعني لو اعلم بس
اشياء مدفوعه اللي هي الاعلانات المدفوعه
بس بدون ما اعلم الاشياء الثانيه واسوي
الاشياء الثانيه بالحمله ترى النتائج اقل
من لما تكون الاشياء الثانيه موجوده بعد
تجربتي كذا جمعتهم مع بعض فعليا تاثر
بالنتائج اللي انت تشوفها وكل هذه ترجع من
تجارب
يمكن احنا من اكثر الناس طبعا احنا نتعامل
مع مشهورات بالغالب شغلنا مع كل المؤثرات
اشتغلت مع العيال
صراحه يا اخي شادين عيال المشاهير شوي
يعني
بين المشاهير العيال والبنات يعني قصدك
العيال اغلى
ولا زين كثير صدق يعني احيانا
يبلغون ترى بالاسعار وصعبين التعامل انا
والله ماني
المشراات في شوي هي ثقه تنبني معهم يعني
قد وصلت مرحله انه ادفع مقدم عشان عنده
مشاكل مدري ايش مثلا تبي تشتري بيت ولا
مدري وش بعد فقلنا خلاص بشتري منك حق سنه
اعلانات واسدد واخذ خصم 60
زي كذا انه هو جايب لك مبيعات قبل فانت
مستحيل على الجميل هذا كيف برضو
يوقف زي النظام يعني واحد من العقود اللي
علينا النظام الجديد حق التوثيق انا قعدت
انتظر خلاص كيف
انا هذا اللي ما يعرفوني بس هذا حق العمل
صار ما يقدر يعلن الا الشخص اللي عنده
رخصه انا اليوم اواجه مشكله لو احد يعلم
وانا دريت في ناس يعلم انا ما ادري ما
دفعت الفلوس
في ناس كثير يعني دائما ضد المشاهير ضد ضد
ضد ضد
ترى انت ما عشت انا شخص ما احب الشهره
وارفض اني اكون ولا ابي ادفع اقدر اخذ
اعلانات وتعال وسوقوا لي ترى صدق ان
القبول من الله مو بايدك يعني بس في ناس
حاولت تشتروا
ترى بعضهم يعني
فاتح بيت عنده مسؤوليات اتعب بالمحتوى ترى
فاقد خصوصيه
ترى من حقه ياخذ فلوس يعني مقابل لكن
المهم انه يحترم يعني بعضهم فعليا صدق صدق
في قله ادب يعني تقول يا اخي ما يستاهل يا
اخي بجيك على مشاكلهم الحين بس انا بعرف
موثوق هذه الحين هل انت ما تقدر
لازم رخصتك وكل شيء وعليك المسؤوليه لو في
شيء صار عندك
المتابع عشان تصير يعني اشوف في البدايه
طبعا صار في مشاكل بحكم الشركات
متابعه المشاهير لا متابعه الشركات
ما اتوقع انهم يحتاجون يتابعون لان كل
مشهور في ناس يكرهونه اول ما
يحتاج يعلمون عليه انا اقول لك هذه مشكله
واجهتني
مثلا يقولون لي انت فلان اعلان عندك اقول
له لا انا ما دفعت فلوس انا ما عندي ولا
في اي شيء فيصير متحمس نزل المنتج وراح
احد بلغ عليه انا مالي دخل
اذا سويت اعلان وانا ما شفت الترخيص اذا
دفعت فلوس بس
انا مع كل جهه حكوميه وزاره التجاره عندنا
موظفين كذا ما شاء الله مع الوزاره طبعا
يعني
الشيطان الحمد لله من الناس اللي احنا
كعملاء احنا عندنا معدله 97% أنا قبل شوي
وقلت لي ترى اشك ان الارقام انا خلال شهر
80 الف تقييم معدل الرضاعه حوالي
فقرات الخاصه بس وزاره التجاره عنده
موظفين مخصصين معنا على طول مجرد طبعا
احنا الحمد لله يعني سمعتها زين عند
الوزاره ليش انا مجرد مع العميل على طول
لان نسبه انه يوصلك منتج طلب ناقص منتج
عندي شوف مستحيل ترى
اوزاره التجاره اوضح من جديد فهم يتابعون
وراكم اذا احد اعلى كل
يومية موضوع التقليد
بس الهيئه العمل والاسبوع مع ترخيص موثوق
اذا جيت انا اعلنت الحين
هو المسؤول هو اللي تحاسب
الشركه واحد
انا مستحيل اعلن الان
صارت صعبه شوي بس انا ما عندي مشكله على
الاقل حافظ حقي وحافظ حقهم الا انا مسوي
معاه عقد موقع الطرفين وشايف رخصته وشايف
ضريب الضريب الزكاه اول نظره
ضريب ولا لا اذا مسجل اعطيني وانا احول
بعضهم صار يرجع تكفى انا الفواتير اللي
راحت والله ما عطيتني
ممكن تدخل تدقق معك اكثر عشان تشوف انت
دفعت له كل شيء
انا يعني
انا عسل الفريق عندي مره بحب الفريق كله
التسويق اللي عندي لكن المواضيع ذي اخلي
كل مدير قسم مسؤول ومكتوب وكل شيء يتابع
المواضيع يعني
ولا ما دقق ولا ما طلب كذا لا ترى الموضوع
حساس كان رقم موظف احنا عندنا ترى خمس
موظفين بس مسؤولين يتابعون
المشاهير يتابعون اعلاناتنا وش صار وش
الاعلان هل في خطا لانه ترى في خطا بعد
احيانا ترى في شيء اسمه
مشاكل المشاهير يعني اليوم لو يدعي ان
المنتج هذا في ادعاء طبي ترى ترجع عليه
وترجع للمشروط ترجع على شوف فيديو شوف
نظام
شفتوا فيها مشاير شوف انا الحمد لله دائما
تعلمت منها
اكره المشاهير تواصل معي
انه والله اعلم انه سيكتب اعلان وزي كذا
فيقول لي زي تكفى مشى لي قلت لا لا انا ما
لي دخل بك هذا انا اعلنت وهذا فلوس
الاعلان هل في
ناسوا على التفاصيل اللي طلبتوها منها
منهم او ان العراق خرب الحمد لله ما صارت
لي
الوزاره تحط قوانين للدرجه دي يعني
بينك وبين المشهور المشاكل اللي تصير
بينكم لانه اخفق في الاعلان او سحب عليكم
تشوفها
وانا يعطيك سعر ويعطي فلان سائر يعني اقل
منك انا ادري انا لي ضريبه مثلا اليوم
يدفعك اي فاسمك كبير تدفع اكثر هذي مشكله
انا كنت اقول لواحد من تجار قبل كذا
نروح على الموضوع خدمه العملاء وكيف تكون
انت قبل الحلقه الارقام 79 شفت الرضا
الارقام العاليه بس خلني اقول 90% فعلا وش
اللي وصلكم بالنسبه لي
انا اشتغلت من البدايه
يمكن في معلومة
القسم الوحيده يرجع لي مباشره على كل شيء
قسم خدمه العملاء بشكل
الاشياء حطيناها اساسيات مثلا
دائما خدمه العملاء لازم تطور نفس الخدمه
نفسها كخدمه انا اليوم
الاغلاط اللي كانت الناس تطيح فيها مثلا
انا مستحيل يطلع من عندي شحنه فيها منتج
ناقص
مشكله تقنيه مستحيل مثلا
توصل عندي يعني كل المشاكل اللي العميل
يواجهها احنا نحله على طول عندنا داخليا
يعني مشاكل التوصيل مشاكل الشحن مشاكل
مشاكل كل هذه نعالج الاغلب المشاكل
يعني مثلا على سبيل المثال كنا نواجه
مشكله منتجات حاره بالصيف هذه اكثر مشكله
بالرياضه
قمنا طلعنا 80 سياره احنا صرنا نوصل داخل
الرياض على شركه شحن
كل السيارات بلوج وباص كبير
وعالجتنا وسوينا بنينا سيستم خاص خاص
بالدليفري حق بس مش مشكله الحراره في
الصيف شو تسوي انه تخلي العميل يقول
المنتجات التجميل واصلح حافظ عندي فعليا
اذا اذا تاثرت تاثر بارد التاثير اذا ما
تاثر يعني متى يتاثر لما يطفي السياره
سواق ويخلي ينازل زي كذا لكن لما يوصل على
طول لا مات بس عشان نزين الاشياء دي حنا
ندور العميل وش عنده مشكله او نتخيل مشكله
تصير نعالج المشكله والتعويضات
يمكن
اذكر عندي بنات خدمه العملاء يقولون زي
العمله ذا يستخدمينها زي كذا
يقول فيها كسر كرتون ترى مو بالمنتج كرتون
ارفع اعطيك فلوسك
تحول الى الاستغلال الا صرت تتعلم شلون
لما يصير العميل عنده طلبين مثلا الطلب
الاول عنده مشكله يقول لي المنتج نازل
يقول ما انت ناقص مثلا طبعا مستحيل تنعكس
اول مره بعطيها انا عادي بعوضه وترى
النسبه اللي عندهم قله الذمه عدد ترى ما
يشكل شيء بالنسبه للمبيعات
فاعطيه فلوس اقول خذ هذه فلوسك
خذ هذه فلوسك وخلي المنتج عندك صدقني مع
الوقت يرجع يروح يتكلم عنك يجيب لك عميل
يدافع عنك شيء ما تتخيل انت
بعض العملاء لا والله اربع مرات خمس مرات
تتكرر حط له حد واقف وما خليه يطلب او طرق
ثانيه وتصور اللي تاريخه جيد معكم ويطلب
طلبات كثير اذا عندهم مشكله خلاص انت
تعلمت يعني حنا نفس التقنيه بناء بحيث انه
ندري العميل وش اللي صادق خلاص صار عندي
بيانات يعني ترى حجم البيانات تعطيك كل
شيء بس
غريب المقارنه متاجر ثانيه نسبه المنتج
عندك
0.5
نعطي فلوس من الرجال
كم معدل الاشخاص اللي
يعني
[موسيقى]
طلع الاشخاص اللي ترجع قليل جدا لانه في
ناس بس يعني عندهم مشكله انه
هو خلوه يضمن انه يلقى احد لا باع عليه
انه يضمن لو عنده مشكله لقى احد يتفاهم
معه بيشتري وبعضهم ترى مشكلته بسيطه حله
بسيط مره يعني
انا اقصد انه الناس تعطيه الضمان عشان
يبين العمل ترى انا اقدر اسمعك ترى انا
انتبه لك ترى انا فلوسك موجود لا يضيق
صدرك باخذ فلوسك زي كذا بس لما تيجي
بالارقام فعليا ترى مو كثير اللي يرجع او
مو كثير حتى في المتاجر الثانيه
على حسب القطاع ملابس كثير ثلاثين بالمئه
قطعنا لها انت تعرف تشتري مسكره خلاص تعال
معروف
متى بترجع اذا عندك مشكله اذا هي فيها كسر
ولا فيها شيء اذا فيها مشكله خلها عندك شو
ترجع لي
على طول نعوض احتماليه انه يكون غير
توقعات العميل قليل
الوصف غير مطابق ترى الداخليا عندنا
بالسيستم خدمه العملاء يرسلها القسم
المنتجات المحتوى المحتوى يرسل المستودع
يروح يطابق فنعالج على طول نعالج المشكله
بشكل سريع جدا كله ترى ماتمت ما في يعني
ما يحتاج انه يدق على المستوى شوف المنتج
هذا لا
كلش يروح عمليات انه اذا جت مشكله على
منتج معين قسم خدمه العملاء يختار التصنيف
المشكله بعدين
يختار التصنيف هم مباشره يعوضونه اذا
عوضوا قال عندي مثلا مشكله خلاني اقول لك
مختلف الوصف غير مطابق فالمشكله هذي تروح
ترسل تروح للمستودع للمستودع
يرجع يرد على خدمه العملاء اليوم
يعني كل شيء وكل قسم في اشياء
وهذا الاستثمار بالتقنيه ونوعيه طبعا كلكم
كلهم نساء اتصور حنا عندنا ثمانيه مليون
تحميل تطبيق النوعيه العميل نفسه الصور
كلهم نساء لا 80% نساء عشرين بالمئه رجال
العطور واكتشفنا شيء ترى الغريب رجال
العطور فاتورته
700 ريال
انا بعلمك اكتشفنا وش قصه العيال البنت
تطلب مكياج وتدخل تاخذ عطر وهي شارع مكياج
وتمشي العيال لا جالسين باستراحه واحد
يسال مين يبي اطلب العطور
فيطلب هذا هذا وشو تعرف الذكيه اللي
بالصراحه اللي يحب يطلب ياخذ الكاش باك
اساميهم نفسهم متكرر طلباتهم يبيع بمحل
طبعا تعرف لازم تعرف عملائك نرجع ندق عليه
كيف تجربتك وشلون وش سويت ومدري ايش وصل
الى اخره فاكتشفنا بس ما في يعني تقسيمه
داخل النساء تقول انه مثلا والله اللي
يشتروا منه اكثر شيء صار في السن فبيصير
كل منتجات هبه واللي يشترون منه اكثر شيء
كبار في السنصير كل منتجاتنا معين فدخلين
بالعملاء في تقسيم واضح في التقنيه هذه
ميزتها انها تساعد غير انا
اليوم اللي هي رحله العميل او شيء اسمه
رحله العميل من يوم يبدا معك لاني اكبر
لاني اشتري لاني خلص احنا نقدر مثلا الفئه
العمريه هذه وش تطلب المدينه هذه وش تطلب
انا اعرف انه مثلا
بالمنطقه مثلا جده يختلفون عن منطقه
الجزاء عن القصيم حتى بطريقه طلباتهم
فمختلف تماما
مثل على البحر اسوي المثال ما يسطرون
والله
يا اخي مره صعبين ليش
فيها ناس تشتغل كافلاين
في عشر محلاتة
بس انه ما شاء الله يعني يطلبون من برا
يعني يعرفونه لكن اقول لك على المناطق
مثلا على سبيل المثال جده مثلا والله كثرت
تان تبيع منتجات تان مدري ايش اكثر عندهم
والله بالرياضه طلب على المنتجات هذه
النوعيه هذه العطور اللي هنا بالمنطقه
هذيك تطلبون عطور نوعك هنا لا تجي انت
علم البيانات صراحه ما كنا كنت مهم كثير
اليوم كيف تجمع تفاصيل اكثر عن الناس عشان
تفهم منهم بالضبط عملائي طبعا من خلال
الشراء
في المنطقه في شيء في ناس هذه تخصصها
الصراحه انه تستنتج من نوعيه المنتجات حل
الاسماء اللي هم البنسه
تقريبا الثلاثه اشخاص او ثلاثه شغلاتهم بس
يطلب وش نحتاج وكيف نتطور بالمستقبل اليوم
لازم بعد تتنبا وش اللي ممكن يصير يعني وش
اللي ممكن
يجيئكم
شف احنا طبعا شركه
الاسهم ولكن بعطيك حجم النمو تقريبا اليوم
مبيعاتنا باليوم
بقول لك نموذج
يا اخي خاف يزعلون عليه الشراكه
رقم فوق كذا عشان بس يعرفون حجمه احنا
متعدين مبيعات 2022 متعدين 500 مليون ما
شاء الله تبارك الله في سنه واحده
كثير قليل ما ادري
تطرحون ان شاء الله نبدينا خلاص اجراءات
وتكملون اوف لاين بس او عفوا اون لاين بس
يمكن هذا من اكثر المواضيع اللي كانت محط
نقاش طبعا اليوم اذا بتهتم تجاره عند
بنيتها قرر قرار عشوائي
مثلا كان اكتشف انه في سوق كبير بالضبط
[موسيقى]
اللي يكون اسهل بكثير يعني حتى ممكن يكون
استحواذ ممكن يكون شراء ممكن يكون لان
السوق حجم النمو الاون لاين اضعاف مستحيل
احد يقدر
انت تتكلم اليوم عن مبيعات يوم واحد اليوم
السنه هذه ترى خمس سنوات ترى مبيعات يوم
واحد عادي تتجاوز مبيعات 2017 كلها يلا
عشان تجيب 500 مليون هذه كم مضطره تصرف
تقريبا
يعني مهما كانت بضاعه ممتازه اذا ما قعدت
تشتغل في التسويق او في الترويج ما راح
تمشي يمكن الناس شوي ثقلانه ارقام التسويق
او قلبهم مات انا اشوف
[موسيقى]
اعلانات مشاهير واثنين اعرفهم
وبعثت ما صرفت ما صرفت ولا شيء اني مثلا
خلني اقول لك
يعني هم يعرفون الاونلاين لازم تصرف
فيحسبون يستهبل عليهم او لا انت في شيء في
عندك مشكله
وفعلا صارت هذه المشكله وزين رحت تكلمت
شرحت له اني انا علاقاتي مع المشاهير
وكانت كذا وانا
بس قلت لك عشان كذا الربح كان يساعدك انك
تكبر اليوم
نقطه وصلها انك ما ينفع تقول مثلا والله
شفت نمو مثلا قاعد
تدري خلني اوفر التسويق وعشان اكسب عشان
اكسبه عشان استغل الفلوس هذا مكان ثاني
انا اليوم
اقول لك انا اكبر واحد متخصص بالتكميل
العطور واقوله بكل فخر تصريح ناري بكل
الارقام ما في تخصص كناس متخصصين بالتجميل
والعطور احنا الاكبر يعني مو بس بالسعوديه
حتى بالخليج في ناس ما شاء الله مجالات
ثانيه طالعين لكن كمجالنا مكاري
بالعكس كل سنه افكر اصرف اكثر
انك توقفت صرف في احفادى
لازم تستحوذ بعد لازم تشتري لازم تاخذ
وهذا هو الهدف يعني
برا السعوديه احنا ما اشتغلنا الصراحه
سوقنا كثير
كل العالم يتهاوشون 85% من سوق الخليج
بالسعوديه
و40% من سوق الخليج في الرياض او اربعين
بالمئه من سوق السعوديه بالرياضه 35%
فانا دائما اقول
القريب ثم لابعد ثم الابعد ثم الابعد يعني
شحن وفي
نيه مستودعات بس مراحل بتكون منطقه ثانيه
بالسعوديه بيكون فيها مستودع ثاني بعدين
شوف انا ترى بالتوسع شوي ماني متهور صدق
يعني
نكبر ونحاول انه يعني
ما نسوي شيء يجيب لنا العيد
قرار جيب بالعيد
اكبر واحد الان في مجال المكياج والعطور
هل اذا جمعتهم مع بعض ولا حتى في العطور
لحالهم ممكن تكون اكبر واحد حتى اشوف يعني
انا ما اقدر اقول شيء يعني ما اعرف تفاصيل
كثيره يمكن ما في شيء
انا متاكد انه حنا غالبا رقم واحد الاون
لاين وش وضعكم اليوم المنافسين في السوق
من منفسكم اليوم قطاعنا كثير
العطور فيه بس مو كثير
ما شاء الله كل شوي يطلع لك اعلان جديد
يختلف ترى احنا نختلف المعرض حق العطور
مختلف تماما عن العطور احنا نبيع
انا لسه ماركات كلها هذه العطور العربيه
مختلفه شيء وترى هذه فيها مو مشكله هذه
اللي الناس انه العطر هذا يجلس
حق الاطراء العطورات اللي تصنع هنا انه
يجلس اربع ايام ثابت على قرتهم ترى فعليا
لو يطلع برا مستحيل يصنعونه برا يعني
التركيز الكحول تركيز يعني وحش جيوبا في
انا بالنسبه لي
ترى والله في ناس
ثبات العطر اربعه ايام انه ما يروح
العطر ثابت ثلاث ايام يومين
ترى هذه ترى يعني
شفت الموضوع صناعه العطور عالم
انا ابي قلت لك استعدى 50 الف عطر الى
اليوم ما صنعنا عطر
كلها عطور مرداد لاني لما بصنع بصنع شي
صدق وتري اتواصل من ثلاث سنوات مع الاسف
كثير هنا ترى مصنع واحد يعبي واحد يحط
الاسم يختار الروائح يركب مو بالكل انا
اشوف في ناس صاروا النظام اللي صممون عطور
يتعمقون مره في الموضوع
هذا ايحاء الصندل على شاطئ البحر مدري شو
لمسه الخشب وفي ناس يحبونه وهي ترى كل
الزيوت وترا الموضوع مو بصاح الموضوع مو
صعب يعني لا في ناس
اصلا هم يدري متطفل على السوق فعليا متطفل
يعني في كم اسم انا اقول راسي سعوديين
ما ودي اذكر اسم احد وانسى احد
اقول لك مثلا
لهم 15 سنه بالقطاع بس في ناس يجي بيوم
يروح معرض معروف او مكان يقول له ابي عطر
يخرق
ولا شيء ترى وترى جيوب صدق ترى حتى الكحول
مضروبه يعني
في ناس ما شاء الله يعني شوف كل سوق اول
ما يبدا مو منظم بعدين يطلع
اشم عطر في الحلقه ولا اعجبني ما عجبكم
قاعد يرسل لي عطور
بس شفت ترى
خلاص الحمد لله ترى العالم عالم عجيب مره
صدق صدق غريب يعني عالم العطور والسنه انا
ماني متخصص اليوم
[موسيقى]
في شيء بالسوق ودي اشرح لك اياه
تعرف الناس اللي بنشوه النجاح هذا لو تروح
لا
شوي يعني
توه مبسوط بالمبيعات ما ما يشكل ما تشكل
معه شيء او ربما انه ما يقتنع انه يسمع
منك او ما يجي يطور معك
في ناس لا نتواصل معهم نقرا على شلون شلون
بنصنع بنتجه فعليا اخذنا خطوات كبير
نبرز بالسوق مع بعض خلنا نشتغل مع بعض
السوق ترك قاعد يتغير من نفسه يعني مع
الوقت
سوق العطور قبل عشر سنين قبل خمس سنين
مثلا
التخصصات اكثر
وترى شيء في اسم مجتهر ولا
يعني سبحان الله رزاق هي بالنهايه يعني
كان عندي عطر واحد
بعدين جاني عطر ثاني حق الاول
صدق تغير وتشتري
كاني سويت
عن 25 نوع عطر
انا يمكن اقول لك اكثر واحد بعطور ماني
مره بالعطور ترى كاستخدام شخص انه والله
كل يوم عطر ولا كل شويه اجرب لا خلاص عطري
عطري هو هو ماشي
في كم كم موضوع كده سريع ودي اخده معك
موضوع تكلمت عنه قبل الحلقه برضه كنت
تقولي انك ولا كنت اسولف معك في كثير بس
ذكرت لي انك توصلون مرحله تجهزوها وصلت
مرحله تجهزون الطلبات بدون تدخل بشري
شف قطع
وكان اول تحدي شلون زي متجر الكتروني
واحنا ما نعرف
تحدي
بالتقنيه وشلون نبني
تجهز الطلبات هذه بدون بكمل لك اياها فقطع
جديد فدائما انا احب اني اسبق الناس اللي
قبله نسوي شيء مختلف المهم قبل سنه ونص
انا واخوي نسولف انه
طال عماله زود عندنا تكاليفهم تزود
والقوانين صعب الساعه والدوله الاشياء هذه
كل خمس عمال لازم تحط سعودي
فرحنا نبحث عن شركات بالاتمه ومدري ايش
المهم ما شاء الله عليها يعني عمر وقت
طويلة بالموضوع هذا ايه
وقعنا مع شركه تقريبا يمكن يكون من اول
المتاجر الالكترونيه اللي بالسعوديه تنفذ
بحيث انه ممكن نطلع عشرين الف طلب بعشرين
عامل باليوم
والباقي كله
بنطبقها ان شاء الله
يجمع الطلب كل شيء
عجيبه احنا شفناها يعني انا واخوي العمال
دورهم
يعني
من ناحيه التغذيه وكيف التغذيه
المخزون عشان تجيب لنفس الجهاز يغطي نفسه
ترى يوزع على كل شيء فاتقني رهيبه
وبنستثمر فيها بنصير اول ناس
تجارب في رعايه الانديه مع التعاون الشباب
كيف كانت تجربه
انا رايت التعاون القصيم ورايت الشباب
بالرياض يتعاون واضح ليش يعني شوي
فعلا انا فرقت معي
الرياض جمهور بسيط وانا يمكن اليوم
منتجك نسائي ليش تروح للكوره
عندي عطور وبدخل اسواق بكره بفتح لاني
العنايه الراجل ترا الراجل يحتاجه
اغراض احتاجه اغراض حلاقه انا بطلب بس انا
شلون اخلي الناس تعرفني اكثر فقلت اجرب
تجربتي كانت صراحه
كنا نعرف بعد الرياضه صرنا فانا اخذت على
نطاق ضيق يعني ما رحت جربت على طول الهلال
وهم باستثمار اشوفه اليوم استثمار الرياض
اكبر جمهور عندك بالسعوديه اليوم
ما في اثر مباشر لكن يبيع سبحان الله يعني
شايفين شيء يبان يعني تعرف اللي يبدا هذا
يتكلم اوه شفت مجرد تتكلم ترى تسال عنك
يعني الناس بدات تتكلم فمالك بكره عندي
كبار مثل الهلال والنصر عاد انا ما عندي
ميول المشكله ابدا صدق
بس
ان شاء الله طلع فعلا التعاون ما بمثله
بالقصيم ولا والله حقهم كلهم
على عيني وراسي يعني
تعصب لا انا احبهم والله كلهم ما تفرق معي
صراحه هم يبزنس فلوس حق الرائد طبعا والله
بصراحه
وكانت فيني يعني في نقاش كبير ما بيني
وبين المستثمرين وما بين اخوي وما بين كذا
انه هل ارعى نادي كبير ولا لا نصبر ناجل
بعض الانديه تقول لك استثمر معي في
احترافيه
تتكلمون
وتشوف في احترافيه
جدا نعم قالت لك جربني بسنتين
حلو
مع
اللي هو بيرجع لك الزمن لاول يوم اسست في
الشركه
بنفس الخبره ونفس التجاره بنفس المعلومات
المشاكل اللي بتصلحها من البدايه
الجواب احيانا يصير
يعني الجواب للنموذجي والله انا اقول بخلي
نفس مكان
الامور كثيره
ما راح من البدايه ابدا
يعني ما اتوقع انه في شغف في نفس الفكره
ما يعني
حتى المجال ثاني بس بنفس القطاع ما اتوقع
وخلاص تحس انك استهلكت كامل فتشوف انت كل
شيء بمساره الطبيعي يعني سبحان الله في
اشياء كثيره ما شفت انا قلت لك الموضوع
ترى مو بكله ذكاء يعني توفيق دائما اقول
التراب يعني الله يعني صار لك سخر لك
اشياء وفتحلك ابواب ولا مو بكلها انه
ذكابك شخص ولكن دائما انا اقول يعني تعرف
اللي يقول اسعى وانا اللي هو الحديث
القدسي او شيء زي كذا انه يسعه وناسه
الكلام بس انه انت ابدا بس ادخل جرب ترى
احيانا تمشي معك كل شيء
لما نقول حظ ولا توفيق من الله ما نقصد
انه اجلس في البيت وفكي ولا اطقطق لا هي
الفكره انه انت كل ما حاولت اكثر كل ما
صارت نجاح انا انا اقول لك يعني الناس
يعني انا اليوم
تكلمت عن تجربه بس انا فعليا عشت وسط
البزنس اشياء انا قد انا انا الان
بالمستودع الكلام
كنا نسافر كنت اسافر بثلج عشان اخذ بضاعه
من ولايه الولايه وقت الثلج عشان ما تروح
على البضاعه
عمره يعني
بيقول لك انا القولون عندي
كل نشترك فيها كلنا ترى الناس ما تتخيل
يعني
انا اقول يعني ترى ما كان شيء سهل ترى انك
تنام تنام وانت عليك فلوس الموردين وانت
ما تدري شو بصير بالتقنيه او تعلن اعلان
عادي يطيح الموقع بكره يا رجل انا كان قبل
اسبوع ما كنت انام تدري ما انام يعني
اسبوع ما نام انام اي لاني اخاف اول يوم
نعلن يطيح الموقع ترى انا دافع كل فلوس
التسويق محطه بثلاث ايام ذي لو طاح الموقع
انت طحت خلاص
يشوفون فلوس يشوفون النجاحون اشياء الزينه
وما الشيء الثاني الضغط النفسي
قصص يعني انا مرات قد قلت
كذا كذا
تقول ما عندي لان الضغط اللي تعيش فيها
طلعت ونزلات يعني
فعلا فالناس دائما لا يعني ترى النجاح مو
يعني مو بسهل ولا بصعب توفيق بس انت حاول
اشتغل افتح قطاعات غريب اسال انا والله
شوف انا اقول لك انت طولت عليك
يمكن انا اليوم شفت انك تسال تدخل عليه
بتويتر برد عليك ولا لا
انا كنت ادفع استشارات الف الف وانا باخذ
أنا
ببلاش كنت اروح للناس واجلس معه ترى عندي
ناس بالشركه يشتغلون الشغله دي بس اروح
اسال اشوف هو اللي عندي يشتغلون صح ولا لا
مثلا كنت اروح ادفع اربع ساعات خمس اسامي
اقول له باجي عندك اليوم يقول لي انا
ادفع 500 ريال بعطيك الف ريال
يروح لهذا ويجلس اسال اسال انشب عادي
وانشب بادب يعني مو في طرق للسعال تقدر
تروح خذ معلومه رحنا لا تصير مستمر يعني
لا تبثر الواحد
فاسال اسال السؤال يعني الله يكتب الخير
مازن اكثر واحد كنت تدق عليه طبعا مره يرد
علي مره يصرف مره لان ترى متعود هو
اسال عادي حاول واليوم اصلا البزنس
تغير سهل جدا
في نصيحه يمكن اخيره بقوله صدق من قال
اليوم في قطاعات لا تقول لي بسوي زي الناس
لا تجي تقول بسوي زي هنقرستيشن بسوي زي
ناس بسيط لكن راح القطاعات سهله اذا تبي
تجاره الكترونيه يعني اكيد تابع الحلقه
في شيء اسمه يعني شفلك منتج واحد افتح لك
منصه واحده اشتغل عليه
الناس انت مثلا تفهم بالشيء هذا اشتغل على
منتج واحد اليوم التقنيه سهله التخزين سهل
ترى اليوم ما عندك لا تقنيه ولا تخزين ولا
اي شيء
لا تتوسع يعني لا تحرق روحك لا تحرق فلوس
واسال زي ما قلت ارجع اسال اسال اسال واذا
سالت اسمع بعض الناس انا كم مره قال لي
واحد يسالني يقول لك
يعني يقول لا انت فاهم غلط لا انا ادري
انا مريت فيه كله شايفة يعني
والله انا يعني
افرح والله اني افرح اني ارد اي والله
واللي ما ارد لان ازعل انك ما انتبهت بس
اليوم
الليله رمضان الحين الله يبارك السحور
واذا في شيء بعد بختم فيه يقول لك دائما
الشريك انا يمكن معي والله اني اقولها
بدون مجامله معي اعظم شريك صدق اخوي تراني
مرات اضعف البزنس يغطي عن مرات هو يضعف
انا غطيانه مرات فعلا انا ما اداوم شهر
عادي خلاص المزاج دمار كل شيء
القوم نفس الادوار ترى حلو انه يصير عندك
شريك تكون متفاهم انت واياه ما انصح احد
يشتغل لحاله لا تشتغل لحالك ترى الشريك
زين وشريك تتفاهم ماديا لا ولازم يعني
جدا تماما يعني انا اذكر بالمكتب انا
اليوم اقول مدير التنفيذي هو عمر هو مديري
بالشركه يعني هو الرئيس التنفيذي انا اكبر
منه بالعمر بس فعلا هو بالشركه انا احترمه
اقول له
لما يجي قرار مرات مثلا موظف زي كذا يقول
لي عمر قال خلاص عمر مدير التنفيذ ما لي
دخل بس في الاستراحه لا بس طلع موظف عادي
اعطي وجهه نظري كمالك بس بالعمل لا قرار
هو اللي يمشي انا احترمه لانه هو مديري
فدائما اذا كنت شراكه لازم واحد مدير
ولازم انت اعطى اقتراحك هو ينفذ ما ينفذ
هو بالنهايه هو اللي يتحمل
شكرا
الف شكر الله يسعدك شكرا قبل ما تقفل
الحلقه اتمنى اذا عجبتك تشاركها مع اللي
حولك وتقيمها بتقييم ايجابي سواء في
اليوتيوب او في ايتونز واذا كان عندكم
ملاحظات عنها ياريتك تشاركني اياها سواء
على ايميل البرنامج سوالف ات 8.com او حتى
على حسابي في تويتر ات دبي شكرا لمتابعتكم
وشكرا لعبد الملك ال سعيد في اعداد الحلقه
ياسر الغانم في اداره التصوير في الاضاءه
غالب محمد ومساعده وياسر في الاخراج
البداعي وهاب موسى في الاخراج الفني مسجد
القرشي في الهندسه الصوتيه عبد العزيز
المزي في التحرير برامج بيبان في التجهيز
عبد المجيد عمر عبد الله بن الفقيه محمد
عبد العزيز وفي الانتاج التنفيذي رزاند
هيثم هذا بزنس احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
للنشر والتوزيع